because in a way they've kind of
automated everything you know what I'm
like women obviously need men more than
men need women but because of like the
way society's structured it's like you
can get an apartment you still have the
safety from the government you can still
get money from the government so women
aren't dependent on men and men it's
like you can get ubereats you know what
I mean like you don't need the comfort
of a chick you can get a hooker like you
can buy everything that you really would
need and now women have the sperm banks
it's interesting to me that men don't do
surrogacy you know it's interesting like
women will go get a child but like men
don't do the same thing as much
typically are the ones that
oh yeah